Assuming we have enough data
to proceed with the analysis,
our next decision is to look at
the outcome we are trying to predict and
determine if it's a numeric outcome or
non numeric outcome.
Numeric outcomes are those where
the outcome is simply a number.
Predicting the demand for electricity or
the hourly temperature
are both numeric outcomes.
Non numeric outcomes are those where
we're to predict the category into which
a case or customer falls.
Such as whether a customer will pay on
time, pay late, or default on a payment.
Another example is whether or
not an electronic device
will fail before 1000 hours.
We generally refer to models that
predict a non numeric outcome
as classification models.
Those that predict numeric outcomes
are known as regression models.